Transcriber: Muhammad Awad
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
كأي طفل آخر يحب أن يركض باتجاه أبيه
بعد أن يعود من عمله،
وفي يوم من الأيام،
وتحديداً بتاريخ 19 نيسان/أبريل 2008،
التاريخ الذي انحفر في ذاكرتي،
في هذا اليوم، تعرضت
لحادث إرهابي في سيارة أبي
لم أفقد يدي اليمنى وأطرافي
السفلى فقط، بل فقدت طفولتي أيضاً.
في عمر الثالثة، تعرضت لصدمة،
وليس من السهل أن تتخلص منها،
ولكن بدعم أهلي وتشجيعهم لي،
أستطعت أن اُكمل حياتي،
وأن أعيشها بصورة طبيعية.
ذهبت إلى المدرسة لاُكمل تعليمي،
ووجدت بالصدفة لعبة المنضدة على الإنترنت،
وأحببتها وشعرت أنني سوف اُبدع بهذه اللعبة.
بعد شهرين، جاء مدرب
المنضدة إلى منزلنا (وهو أحد أصدقاء والدي).
شجعني على هذه اللعبة خطوة بخطوة،
وعلّمني عليها من الصفر.
تدربت عنده لمدة 6 أشهر متواصلة تقريباً،
بعد ذلك شاركت ببطولة
في العراق، وحصلت فيها على المركز الأول.
ثمّ ألتقينا برئيس اللجنة
البارالمبية ورئيس اتحاد كرة الطاولة،
بعد أن شاهدوا ما قدمته في البطولة،
واستدعوني لتمثيل المنتخب مباشرة،
وشاركت في عدة بطولات خارج لعراق،
وحصلت على المركزين الأول والثاني.
(تصفيق الجمهور)
شاركت في 13 بطولة تقريباً خارج العراق،
وحصلت فيهم على المركزين الأول والثاني.
تحديت نفسي والمجتمع الذي كان يتنمر علي،
ومن حالات التنمر التي مررت بها
عندما كنت صغيرة، كان يتنمر علي العديد من
الأطفال عندما أخرج إلى الشارع أو المدرسة،
كانوا يتنمرون ويقولون لي:
“لماذا لا تملكين يداً وأقداماً مثلنا؟”
فلم أستطع أن أفعل أي شيء سوى البكاء.
في يوم من الأيام، ذهبت إلى أمي
وقلت لها: “لماذا لا
أملك يداً وأقداماً كالبقية؟”
“اُريد أن ألعب وأمشي
مثلهم، لماذا أنا مختلفة عنهم؟”
“لماذا يركضون ويلعبون وأنا جالسة؟”
فقالت لي أمي: “سيعوضك
اللّه بشيء كبير عندما تكبرين”
“بشيء لا تتوقعينه وسيُرجعهم لكِ.”
كنت صغيرة ولم أفهم ما الذي تقصده في كلامها
ولكن عندما كبرت وشاركت في أول
بطولة خارج العراق وحصلت على المركز الأول،
من هنا فهمت ما الذي تقصده أمي في كلامها،
إن رب العالمين عوّضني
بأشياء كثرة بدلاً من يدي وساقي،
عوّضني بالإرادة والقوة وبهذه العائلة
(تصفيق الجمهور)
إن الإعاقة لا تمنع
أحد من تحقيق حلمه ومراده،
فبإصرارنا وعزيمتنا
نستطيع الوصول إلى ما نُريده.
في البداية، كنت ألعب على الكرسي،
ولكن شخصياً لم يشعرني ذلك بالراحة،
فانتقلت إلى فئة الوقوف على الأطراف،
وعند انتقالي إلى هذه الفئة،
استخدمت هذه الأطراف كالتي ترونها
وهذه الأطراف فقط للمشي وليست رياضية.
وكانت ساقي تؤلمني في كل مرة ألعب بها،
لكنني كنت أتحدى الألم واضغط على
نفسي لأُحقق نتيجة لصالح العراق
وأن أرفع اسم العراق
لأنني جئت لتمثيل بلدي ولدي هدف
(تصفيق الجمهور)
والحمدللّه تحديت الألم الذي مررت به
وحصلت على المركز الأول في بطولة تايلاند،
وأنا شخصياً أتحدى الألم
في كل بطولة لأرفع اسم العراق.
فمثلاً هناك موقف في
بطولة تايلاند (وهي أول بطولة لي بالأطراف)
كانت ساقي تؤلماني جداً
وكنت سأواجه اللاعبة الكورية
التي ساُنافسها على المركز الأول،
رغم الألم الشديد إلا أنني
ضغطت على نفسي كي لا أرجع مهزومة
كنت أقول لنفسي: “هيا يا نجلة!
لم يبقى سوى نقطة، هيا يا نجلة أسعدي أهلك.”
(تصفيق الجمهور)
والحمدللّه حصلت على
المركز الأول في بطولة تايلاند.
ومن أهم الإنجازات التي أفتخر بها أيضاً
هو تأهلي إلى بارالمبياد طوكيو 2021
وبعمر 16 عاماً وكأصغر لاعبة في العالم.
(تصفيق الجمهور)
لعبت مع لاعبين مصنفين ثاني ورابع عالمياً
رغم قلة الدعم وأدوات الرياضة
واستخدام الأطراف غير الرياضية
لكن الحمدللّه هذا الشيء لم يوقفني
وحققت المركز الخامس في بارالمبياد طوكيو
(تصفيق الجمهور)
وقبل يومين، كنت في بطولة آسيا
في البحرين وحصلت فيها على المركز الأول.
(تصفيق الجمهور)
ويُعتبر أول وسام ذهبي
لدورة الشباب في هذه البطولة لكرة الطاولة.
نصيحتي لجميع الناس الذين يشاهدوننا
حالياً، خاصةً من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة،
لا تتوقفون ولا شيء مستحيل،
فبإصرارنا وعزيمتنا
نستطيع الوصول إلى ما نريد،
يجب أن لا نبقى مكتوفي الأيدي وأن
لا نجلس في منزلنا ونتظر الشيء الذي نريده،
يجب أن نسعى ونواصل المضي ونتعب
لنصل إلى ما نريد
وأن نحول أي شيء سلبي إلى إيجابي.
حلمي لم يتوقف هنا،
اُريد أن أكون مقدمة
برامج رياضية وأن أدرس الإعلام،
وأريد أن أحصل على الميدالية
الذهبية ليس فقط على مستوى آسيا،
بل على العالم في البارالمبياد القادمة.
(تصفيق الجمهور)
انتظرونا قريباً بالميدالية
الذهبية في بطولة العالم إن شاء اللّه.
(تصفيق الجمهور)